my name is patty and
I am pro-life, I had two abortions. I know what happens to the emotional and psychological
part of women
My name is John and I'm pro-choice
I did six years of the planned parenthood of Golden Gate
My name is Marie and I am pro-life and I help women
Reverse their abortion once they've started them if they would like to do so
Nooo, don't do it
I'm the only one?
Uh well a sandwich is just something between two pieces of bread and that's what a hot dog is
I disagree because ... *laughter*
A sandwich is two pieces of bread, right? But a hot dog bun isn't two pieces of bread.
A hot dog is it's own thing
It's just the way it's eaten is different
If you had a hot dog bun and you put like deli meats in there, would that be still a hot dog?
Would it be a sandwich then?
that would be a hotdog though
Are we gonna solve world peace here?
Oh right, we start talking
Yeah, because you hear the other person's perspective and you're like, okay that makes sense
Yeah, no, I think I question mine often because I could imagine that if I wasn't living my life based on my christianity,
I would want women to have that choice as well
I used to be a pro-life feminist
Really?
Yes, until I had an abortion
Actually I had two
And after I realized what I had done, I knew I had made the biggest mistake in my life
I realized it wasn't my.. I shouldn't be taking the life of a child
So after that I struggled with it for 35 years with my abortions
So I have no doubts, I am all the way
Pro-life!
But I believe, fundamentally, that the woman should have that right to make the decision and I've never been anybody who's pro-abortion
and oftentimes they don't have good choices and
they're picking the lesser of the bad choices
yeah I just feel like
I'm very certain of my views because I
want to respect that everyone has that option
and I think that if you take that away,
you endanger children more than if you allow them to make that choice for themselves, so
But a woman can choose for herself but
She doesn't have the right to choose for someone else because if a child is inconvenient as a toddler,
are you going to kill that child as a toddler? No.
I think we're talking about a completely different thing though
But no we're talking science
And I'm saying like a lot of times women have to have abortions because of medical reasons
That's like .001%
Right
Time?
Oh, you got us
Right in the thick of it
My sister had an abortion
Almost two years ago, I found out I was pregnant and had an abortion forced on me by a man twice my age
Who made a ton of money and I felt like i had no other choice
If I wasn't a christian and if I didn't believe the things that I believe, I would
be pro-choice, like 100%, but at the end of the day, like to my core, I believe that all human
life is so sacred and
it's not our choice, it's never been our choice
I realized that I shouldn't have had that choice because I was choosing life and death over
another human being, it's taking a life
But I do understand, definitely understand, where you guys came from
The only difference we have is when that
fetus becomes a human life
If that's a human being, then my tonsils a human being
I think there are very great..
That's a scary grey area
And in the bible, you didn't say, you know, I don't know what part of christianity but
Jesus says before I formed you in your mother's womb, I knew you and not a sparrow falls from the sky without my knowing
I feel like I really respect you and your faith
I respect that that's your feeling and that you all feel that way, but I also feel like
one can feel that way regardless of the Bible, regardless of Christianity, you know it's one of those things that
happens and has happened, actually for decades, you know for a while and
people
make that decision and it is their decision, they make that decision
for
whatever reasons. You know? Again, you help people who have taken a pill first then change their mind and I think that's great
But if you have one and you feel regretful then deal with it.
If you have one, you don't really feel regretful or you feel
like it really truly was the best decision for you, then that's what happens and I just think we all know people like that or
I'd just don't feel like we have any right to
force a particular way and you know, I think it's great to try to just be open, you know?
Pretty judged around my beliefs
Hey guys
How you been?
It's been a long time
I think we all feel that way because because it's an emotional,
very emotional topic
I've actually been verbally attacked by a lot of the pro-choice people
you know about what I went through, with the regret, the alcoholism, and all of that stuff that tied into the abortion
For me, something that Marie said a little bit while ago about
her Christian faith and implicit in that is that someone who's pro-choice isn't Christian
I was raised a Roman Catholic. I  consider myself a Christian.
I don't believe that there's anything in Christianity, as I understand it,
that requires me to believe that abortion is murder
I grew up in a Christian home, my mom's a pastor, but
they also respect that
they know that it's my ultimate decision and they know that what it is that I'm gonna do, what I'm gonna choose for my life,
they don't have control over and that I am an adult
Sometimes in the argument, between the two sides
there's a lack of respect for the fact that, like, I don't have to agree with you
You live your life the way that you want you and I'll live it the way I want to, as long as you're not stopping...
Aw
Sorry you guys
I have two kids, one a son who's 30
and then a daughter who's 28
I have one son, who is 36, he's adopted
I couldn't have children biologically
I convinced a doctor to give me a tubal ligation because I didn't feel I punished myself for having the abortions
I have a daughter, she's a year old, and she's in heaven
To me
in my experience at planned parenthood, almost everybody had kids and
the slogan, if you will, of Planned Parenthood was "no child an unwanted child"
And we wanted our children and that's why we chose to have them
What about all the people that would gladly take care of that child, that cannot have a pregnancy to save their life?
Well because a woman has to go through..
Nine months for a whole life that a child could have?
I think one of the things that I really immediately reacted to is that
Okay, nine months, whatever, but there are so many children, not just in America, but the world over
that don't have loving parents, that are not in a loving situation, that are not cared for, fed, clothed,
loved! And I think that is the most important thing, to care about our children, because they are our future
So the child in the womb has no value whatsoever?
No, I don't think so at all. I'm not saying that, I never said that
Okay, I'm just asking, yeah
I'm just saying that to me that's unclear
whether it's you know, this or that or this or that, and despite the fact that you say
there are people out there that want to adopt this child or want to take care of this child, there are still so many that are not
And that's horrible
I don't think that wrong makes this right though
No, I understand that, I'm not saying that, I'm only responding to your comment
My view is I don't want to, personally, want to have kids. I want to adopt all my children because of that reason
And because I lived with a family that took me in, when my family didn't want me
And so I understand that
One, the foster system and adoption is not that easy
and if we're making it about
taking care of the child, yeah, let's do that, let's take care of the children
But we need to make sure that there are
opportunities in place for all the children to be successful
so that that child has a world to come  into that's actually gonna be good to it because we don't live in
that world right now
We don't offer those things to our children
You should talk to a lot of the people that came from a ton of
adversity who've now made it in this world
We're not talking about that, we're not talking about the success
We're talking about kids today that do not have a home
Yeah, and their worth, that worth, in my opinion,
is exactly equal to a twenty week baby in a womb
I totally understand and I respect that
I'm only saying, my only comment was
I feel like it's unfair to be, like
"Well, Blah, blah, blah! Nine months, why can't you just have a kid for nine months and they give it up?"
Ohhhh cool
It is getting cooler in here, though, isn't it?
It is
Um
I wasn't expecting to hear some of the stories about people's
lives and their experiences,
who've had abortions and
like, I can only imagine the pain
that is associated to making that decision and I have a lot of
compassion and sympathy for people who go through that
I wasn't expecting, i wasn't expecting, it to be as calm as it was
I think that there were moments, but I think, for the most part, we were
respectful of each other and
I still think that you guys are awesome people, I mean, outside of this situation
I wasn't surprised at how this has gone because when we were all talking outside it didn't make any difference
whose side was on whose side and we all bonded right away, you know,
Sometimes,
our levels got a little bit raised but, you know what,
we all respect each other
No matter what you do, you've heard all the arguments
there's not gonna be one argument where you're like "Oh my gosh, you just changed my mind"
No, it's never gonna, you know, people are who they are and it usually takes a certain situation
happening, but I think it's healthy to have the dialogue.
I think it doesn't happen enough, it happens too much behind our computers
Oh ok
It's cool
Sorry dog
Nice meeting you! Nice meeting you!
It was great
Great meeting you, sweet thing